I spent many a day of my teenage years
visiting my then-boyfriend who was being
detained at Her Majesty's pleasure in
Hitchin prison home I will never forget
picking him up at the prison gets him
wearing his prison-issue clothes and
with all of his belongings in a
transparent carrier bag we drive home
back to these day me full of optimism
that this time would be different and
him determined that it would be sir yes
inevitably the cycle would repeat itself
somewhere down the line not because he
was a bad person was because then that
was the only life that he really knew
and this experience has made me
passionate in my belief that we need to
consider prisons different differently
yes it absolutely must be a place of
punishment and I'd argue even more so
than it currently is but if we want to
reduce the reoffending rate which by the
way across society up to 15 billion
pounds a year then we must also focus on
rehabilitation and re-education and I
was pleased therefore when I heard this
week that more prisoners will now be
allowed a release to enter the world of
work and that hundreds of new employers
have signed up to be part of this scheme
however unpalatable it may seem to some
if we truly want to break the cycle we
must start doing things differently when
it is safe to do so should start with a
word of praise for private enterprise
here a company called Timpson switch
ends Johnson's and Jeebs dry cleaners
snappy snaps Mac's Spielman I've not
heard of and various others good luck to
them they make a point so things like
that is to be encouraged let me ask you
and you've got a obviously closer
Association fortune than I through your
ex-boyfriend
why is prison failing well it's not just
it's not just that prisons failing in
its terms that well actually it is in
some instances I think when you're going
to prison you've got to be there as a
deterrent and a punishment and if I
speak of my experience with my ex it
quite like she's in there Oh various
different thing as you know nothing like
mad or anything like that various lower
level bits and pieces but for him he
went into prison he saw his mates he got
free access to a gym he got some decent
food and he didn't mandate quite frankly
so you know you've wanted to benefit
from a scheme such as the one that was
line this week if it was offered to him
then possibly possibly not but I would
argue that actually so many
organizations they already employ people
with criminal records ex-offenders they
don't know about air because as the the
Timpson sky quite rightly points out
people have to lie on their applications
to get into business if they've got a
conviction often they have to lie about
it just before I yield this is what the
government saying in the shape of
Justice Secretary David Gork I think
it's really important that we offer
people a second chance all the evidence
shows that those who leave prison and
then go into work are much less likely
to rear fender so that's what the
Justice Secretary is saying to former
justice ministers Mike penning and Sir
Oliver heeled to broaden it out is
saying that the early release of
prisoners
is wrong and that as and when you're
sentenced to a term you'd have a minute
yes just no but I'm just broadening it
out the idea of your sentence to six
years
you're not it's three years and as you
set fly to the jail well what they're
talking about just a broadening out of
it is you're set a minimum term or a
maximum term and you can take time off
the maximum term if you move into a work
scheme and you are seen to go into a
whole heartedly and actually work
towards it you will bring down the time
spent that would seem to be an another
added incentive really to abiding by
I've got a question mister this raises
to me a question in my mind which is
that why don't we just cut out the
middleman the number the prison
population has gone up fourfold since
1950 there are 82,000 people in prison
in England and Wales as against 20,000
in 1950 do you think your boyfriend
should have been in prison for what he
did I mean the reoffending rate is 64%
so why don't you just how to take an
offender don't put them in prison just
put them straight into work what no I do
think that he should have been in prison
wait obviously doesn't work being in
prison I do think kept going back in
yeah but the reason the reason that
people reoffended is quite complicated
when you come out of prison and you go
back in our case to these day two the
same crowd at people to the same daily
life that you had before you went into
that environment it's nothing changing
nothing works if you take people out of
the prisons and you show them a
different way of life so you show them
you can go into work
you can be trusted you can get skills
you can earn money because by the way I
think I'm convinced that some of
Britain's best entrepreneurs are behind
bars and when you look at some of the
entrepreneurial dreams coming in Paul
it's insane
great I am I've been involved in
charities for some while and I'm just
joined one what I was a trustee where we
we're trying to link up the prisons with
the local football clubs and I think
they're making some success but when I
the statistic that concerned me most
when I was when I first got involved in
business was what something like 10% of
journalists kids become journalist 15%
of of lawyers kids become lawyers 65% of
prisoners sons become prisoners and the
and amongst women the figure is even
higher there's far fewer women in prison
but it seems to me that's what that's
where I agree me entirely you've got to
know you're not only affecting this
generation you're affecting the next
generation and it's quite encouraging
I think this government on this whole
area of prisons and justice has been
rather good it's been quite a liberal
it's been trying to it worked out you
can't just go from I made a program
years ago we said if the number of
prisoners went about 40,000 we'd have a
crisis you said it's now 80 odd thousand
you can't just keep putting more and
more people in prison you've got to do
something about it and I think what
you're saying is right you know my sort
of soft liberal persona says this is the
right thing to do but I I wonder about a
couple of aspects of this first of all I
wonder if we're that good at judging who
should be eligible for de release
because one thing you said is you know
not all not all people who get convicted
of crimes are quote unquote bad people
they are as you say people were in
tricky circumstances or faced
difficulties in their lives and oddly
enough paradoxically in some cases
actually staying behind bars away from
the world might be the best thing for
some of them not for everybody not for
it but it was some people who for
example
our drug addicts or some people who let
them out eventually
you've got let them out but my point is
that I'm not sure that with that great
at understanding exactly how to make the
judgment at the moment and that would be
my worry about this simply to say you
know it's nice for anybody's for people
to say let's give everybody day release
but that might not be the right thing
for everybody and I just don't know if
we've got the mechanism to make the
distinction on you've got to have a
proper thought through framework and at
the moment the new proposals are that
you've got to have been in for three
months before you can be eligible for
this it used to be twelve I think so
you're already starting to understand
the character of the person and you need
to be sensible about the work placements
I mean if someone's been convicted of a
sex offense against a child is not gonna
put them into the nursery Darrel ease
paid employment yeah exactly so it is
like to your point it's open jails we're
talking about its women's prisons it's
people on the lower end of the the
criminal spectrum if that's them that's
the way and for me I just think if you
truly want to get people rehabilitated
which we should and I told you how much
it's customers think it's 15 billion you
have to start understanding the psyche
of these people and stopping them from
just putting back into the world from
which they originally came with no new
knowledge of a world outside of that but
you need to put I think we need before
we did do it you'd have to put a lot of
resources into it and you'd have to make
sure that the social services and prison
servers have the skills which I really
doubt actually at the moment they've got
the people capable of doing we've hacked
it we've hacked the support systems when
they come out of prison death because I
agree because of the cuts and that's the
real issue
hey we're moving on steady yourself cuz
I've got some exciting news for
everybody for the first time in pledge
history and this is massive
shut up moon we have decided to give our
very prestigious straight talker award
to the same person for the second week
in a room look at how excited these
faces
oh man so honored by the recognition he
received from this show last week he
couldn't wait to heat the press back on
the pledge when he told his listeners
all about us on his absolute radio show
yes Frank Skinner I'm talking about you
so let's have a listen there's a program
on Sky which I don't if you're aware of
it it's a sort of a lowbrow debate show
called the pledge and they've got
opinions and that and I'm not saying
they're not imbeciles but they don't
really know the topics they're there for
a bit of you know it's called the pledge
by the way I think because it named
after pledge you know that the
multi-surface cleaner because he cleans
away any sort of nuance or subtlety or
finer points of an argument leaves its
mark and basic they were easy to see
trivial Frank I think you like is really
[Laughter]
the real ledges at the pledge Frank
Skinner you are a returning straight
talker every week coming out ago if you
think you're good enough right that's it
from us for this week we've got some
cleaning to do but don't forget you can
join in the debate by searching for the
pledge on Facebook or Twitter and you
can even take the debate with you by
subscribing to the new pledge podcast
which is available on iTunes thank you
for watching if you need any cleaners
you know where we are
[Music]